[MUSIC PLAYING]
JORDAN THIBODEAU: We're
joined by Boyd Varty.
Boyd was raised in Londolozi
game reserve in South Africa.
He currently lives and
works at the reserve.
And his most recent
projects include
advocating for restoration
of ancient elephant corridor,
helping the Good Work
Foundation create more learning
centers in South Africa.
He wrote a book
called, "Cathedral
of the Wild" about his
experiences at Londolozi.
Londolozi has been in his
family for four generations now.
And he's going to join us
here to share his experiences.
So let's give him a
warm round of applause.
BOYD VARTY: Thank you, so much.
JORDAN THIBODEAU:
So starting off,
can you talk about Londolozi?
BOYD VARTY: Sure, so Londolozi,
the story of Londolozi begins
like a lot of good
stories with the intake
of large quantities of gin.
And it begins in 1926 with my
great-grandfather at a tennis
party in Johannesburg.
And he heard about these
bankrupt cattle farms
that lay adjacent to
the Kruger National Park
in the wild eastern
part of South Africa.
And they had come up for sale
because they were bankrupt.
And they were bankrupt
for two reasons.
The one was that it's very
rough terrain out there.
It's low rainfall.
It's a difficult
area to operate in.
And the other was
that lions were
eating all of the cattle that
roamed at the cattle ranch.
And in 1926, my
great-grandfather
was an adventurer.
He was a hunter.
And this place that sounded
terrible to everyone else,
sounded like a wild
place where you
could go and have an
adventure to him, where
you could go and hunt lions,
particularly, hunt lions and go
and hunt animals.
And so sight unseen, after
too many gin and tonics,
they bought the property.
And they went down there for
the first time in June of 1926.
And it was a whole
rigmarole to get there.
You had to go out to these
sort of real border towns.
And they caught a train.
And the train ran through the
southern part of this property.
And they bribed the
train driver to stop.
And they got off and they
walked on a compass bearing
directly north into
this wild hinterland.
They didn't know
where they were going.
Halfway along the way, the
porters who they had with them
said, well, this is madness.
We're being led to death here.
And my great-grandfather
spoke a bit of Zulu.
And he was able to talk
them into keep going.
And eventually, just
as night was falling,
they arrived under this
big beautiful ebony tree
on the banks of the river.
And that's where they sort
of set up their first hunting
camp.
And the hunting camp was--
and I should tell you
that the story moves
away from hunting.
And I think the
story of this place
holds so much of what I
think is pertinent today.
So you know what they did
is they went there to hunt.
And they came down
every year in the winter
to hunt lions and leopards.
And there wasn't a
lot of game there.
The property was very run down.
It was eye-high scrub.
And they built these
three mud huts.
It was very rudimentary.
I'm told that people,
when it rained,
would go and stand outside of
the accommodations for shelter.
Because the accommodations
were so leaky and open.
But for three generations,
that's what happened.
They went there and they would
hunt, particularly predators.
And then in 1969, my
grandfather died very suddenly.
And my father and my uncle
were about 14 and 15 years old.
And they were told by all of
the family advisors, look,
you've lost your father now.
You need to look
after your mother.
And the first
thing is you've got
to get rid of that wild
place where you go and hunt.
Hunting is a bad
idea to start with.
And you got to get rid of it.
And they said, no, we feel
compelled towards that place.
We feel called to it.
And they said, well,
how are you going
to look after your mother?
And as teenage boys, and
I think this was probably
the beauty and arrogance
of youth, they said,
we will make it pay.
And that's how my family got
into the safari business.
These two young
boys decided they
would make this place viable.
And they decided that they would
take the entire safari business
in one go.
They would do canoe
safaris, hunting safaris,
walking safaris.
And people would come down
and stay in these mud huts.
And the first canoe safari, they
hit a hippo with their canoe.
So they canceled canoe safaris.
The walking safaris were
always a bit of a mess.
And so it was very, you
know, they had one Land Rover
that they would drive around.
But it only turned to the left.
And if you went
there, the other thing
was in a month or
two of being there,
you might see very sparse
game, a few antelope, maybe
the occasional lion or leopard.
And it was trying to
get away from you.
And so they were trying
to do this endeavor.
But they had no guidance.
And it was a pretty
ropey operation.
And then they had a
real defining encounter.
They met a man by the
name of Ken Tinley.
And Ken was this
fascinating character.
He had dropped out
of high school,
but then been admitted into
a biological sciences degree.
Because he drew a picture of a
moth with such intricate detail
that the dean of the biology
faculty said to him, OK,
you're in.
And then he had worked as
a scientist in the Kruger
National Park, where he
hadn't been well-received.
Because he was a real
early believer in the idea
that all things are connected.
And he was sounding
off on people's
intellectual territory,
the expert on lions,
the expert on elephants.
And he was saying we need
to look at it holistically.
So he wasn't so well
received in the Kruger.
And he went to a reserve
in Mozambique for awhile.
And he lived in solitude
for about a year.
And during that time, he walked
in this wild, vast landscape
of this reserve in
Mozambique called Gorongosa.
And he mapped the
topography, drawing by hand.
And he developed this
incredibly intricate sense
of how a landscape fits together
and how the topography informs
the flow of water and how
that informs your soils
and how that tells you
which fauna and flora you've
got there.
But he thought
very holistically.
And almost his connection
to the wilderness, it
almost lived inside of him.
He felt it very deeply.
And then the war broke
out in Mozambique.
And he ran back to South Africa.
And he arrived, he sort
of washed up into the camp
where I grew up.
And he met these two young men.
And very soon after my mother
had also moved to live there.
They were living in these really
rudimentary accommodations.
And they didn't really
know what they were doing.
They were trying to
start a safari company.
They had this vision
that they would get
people to come on the safari.
But it wasn't really working.
And he said to them, if you
want this place to work,
and this was really the defining
moment or one of the defining
moments, you need to
partner with the land.
You need to begin to think
of the animals as your kin.
You need to think of them as
a part of an extended family
of beings.
And you need to make sure that
the local people participate
in the well-being of this place.
And they said to
him, well, restore
the land, partner with the
land, what do you mean?
And he said, come,
I'll show you.
And he took them out
onto this terrain.
And where the cattle had grazed
the land bear, what you get
is bare ground.
And then when the rain falls,
you lose all of that moisture.
And then as you
lose the moisture,
you get scrub coming in.
And the scrub
starts to take over.
And he showed them how you could
clear the scrub away and plug
it into where you were
losing the moisture,
in these deep, erosive furrows.
And it's kind of like putting
the plug back in a bath.
And as you do this work
of clearing the scrub
and restoring these
micro catchments,
suddenly the grassland
started to come back.
And so they started this
work of restoring the land.
And suddenly, there
would be grasslands.
And then one day,
you would come out
and where there had
been no animals,
suddenly there would
be a herd of zebra
and then suddenly a
herd of wildebeest.
And slowly, and then they
started to see nyala.
And there was this real sense
that as they had this intention
to work with the land, the
land was starting to respond.
And about six or seven
years into that process,
they had another real
defining encounter.
And it was late one afternoon.
They had been
working on the land.
They were driving home in
this beat up old Land Rover.
And into the late afternoon
light, in front of them,
in front of their Land
Rover, about 200 yards
in front of them, a leopard
stepped out onto the road.
And she was a young
female leopard.
And instead of running away
like every other leopard had
done ever that
they had seen, she
stopped in the late afternoon
light and she looked at them.
She gave this little growl.
And they saw she had
this one broken canine.
And they watched
her for a moment.
And there was this really
strong sense of, for a moment,
they were allowed to see her.
She granted them
this moment with her.
And then she stepped off
the road and disappeared.
And they drove home
together in silence.
And I don't know
if you've ever had
sort of a scary encounter in
a vehicle where you pull over
and then everyone
just sits there
for a moment in
absolute silence.
And then my father
looked at my uncle
and he said, whatever just
happened, that's my future.
And I think it's
such an amazing thing
to have an encounter like that
with your destiny in life.
And so for the next
about 10 or 12 years,
he woke up every
morning and he teamed up
with a local tracker Shangaan
man called Elmon Mhlongo.
And every day they went out
and they tracked that Leopard.
And slowly, sometimes days would
go by, they didn't see her.
And then they would see
her from a great distance
and she would disappear.
And then they would see
her from a great distance
and she would allow
herself to be seen.
And over the course
of years, they
started to build
the trust where they
could get closer and closer.
And eventually, it
got to the point
where they would sit
in a Land Rover here,
and she would be where
you're sitting over there,
lying close by.
And then one day, they
were watching her.
And they knew she had
cubs somewhere nearby.
Because they could see
that she was lactating.
But they didn't think the
cubs were anywhere close by.
And a cub came out of the
grass and ran up to the mother
and jumped onto her head.
And there was this
very strong sense
that as they worked on the land,
as the land started to recover,
this emissary appeared
from the wild side.
This leopard came out to
them and slowly allowed
herself to be seen.
And that leopard became
known as the mother leopard,
because she went on to have
a number of litters of cubs.
And all of those cubs grew up
modeling their mother's trust.
Suddenly they knew that the
people here meant no harm.
So they would allow
themselves to be seen.
And so in the middle of
apartheid South Africa
where no one wanted
to go, suddenly word
started to get out
all over the world
that there was this
place you could
go to and see a wild leopard.
And that lives in the psyche,
in the human psyche, the mystery
of it, the beauty
of it, the pull
of being able to have an
encounter with that cat.
And so she became
the mother leopard
because she was the
mother of these cubs,
but also because she gave an
incredible amount of momentum
to this place where I grew up.
Suddenly it became a place
where people wanted to come.
Suddenly more people
started to come.
As they started to come,
an economy of wildlife
started to be established.
So we established a
little village there.
Local people started working
in the tourism industry.
And we became all unified in
the protection of this place
as a means of looking
after our own families.
And it was like this
relationship developed.
As we cared for this place, it
really started caring for us.
And so when I think about what
I do, it's really to tell people
that I have seen a restoration.
I have seen a place
where we've gone
from being at war with nature
to back in relation with it.
And I have seen the
effects that that
can have on the people
who live on that land.
You start to experience yourself
as belonging to a place.
And it's this very
primary belonging.
You know that it's important
for you to be here.
And your value is
present with you
in the relationship
with the place.
You know the animals
as a part of you.
It's different every day.
But there's this
sense of kinship.
It's a very fundamental,
psychological belonging.
And I think that a lot of
the anxiety that we see
and the depression that
we see in modern life
is undiagnosed homesickness
for belonging to a place,
for knowing yourself in
relation to other creatures,
and for feeling
yourself as a part of.
I always say that in a society
where the individual self is
disconnected from the greater
whole, the search for meaning
is reduced to how I am
doing in comparison.
And that's sort of the
opposite of what you experience
when you live in wilderness.
Because you know yourself
as belonging to all of this.
And then the meaning
starts to change radically.
The meaning becomes
about us in relation.
about sharing.
The meaning becomes
about being together, not
competing against.
And that's a very
interesting experience
to have in the wild
animal of your own body.
So that is what I grew up in.
And that is what has
informed the sort of work
that I want to do and the
message that I want to spread.
JORDAN THIBODEAU:
Also, the game preserve
is known for the elephants you
brought back to the territory.
Can you talk about how
you guys went about it?
BOYD VARTY: Yeah,
so what happened was
is that there was a fence
that ran between our reserve
and the Kruger National Park.
And the fence was called
a veterinary fence.
But it was actually erected
by the apartheid government
to use the Kruger
National Park as a buffer
zone between Mozambique
and South Africa.
The fence had absolutely no--
to put a fence between wildlife
and wildlife is madness.
And a lot of animals
died that would
have moved in that area,
died against that fence.
And very early on, we
wanted the elephants
to return to Londolozi.
And so my father
and uncle set off
to do the first ever
live elephant relocation.
And this was in the '70s.
And they actually
caught elephants
in the Kruger National Park
and moved them in trucks
back into this area to
re-establish their presence.
And they successfully did that.
Although, there were many
mishaps along the way.
They didn't have crates big
enough for the elephants.
They put an elephant
in an antelope crate.
And it breathed in and
the crate fell apart.
And so there was all
sorts of shenanigans
in trying to move
elephants to this place.
But very quickly we
realized that that was not
the way to do it.
The real thing to
do is to advocate
for the removal of the fence.
And that is something
that, after Nelson Mandela
came to power in 1994, we
were actually able to achieve.
And the fence came down.
And as the fence came down,
it's this incredible thing
to go from having these few
elephants that had been brought
in, to watching this natural
rhythm of elephants flowing
back into the reserve.
And going from a
couple of elephants
to, in the winter months,
1,500 elephants coming
into the reserve from
Kruger National Park,
walking up the river.
I mean, at certain
times in the winter,
our camp is on the
river, and you come out.
And every day there's elephants
down there in front of you.
And it's this feeling
that they've returned
to where they belonged.
And so anywhere,
and the core of it
is to return to this
more natural state
and live amongst it.
Yeah, so that's
been a huge victory.
And a part of what
I see is this place
having been a part
of the restoration
is that it's not conservation.
And particularly,
in these times,
it's not standing at the end
of any wild places we have left
and saying, please, can we
protect what we have left?
It's starting to
say, no, if we start
to think about restoring, we
can actively go and reclaim,
start to bring
nature back to life.
But it comes out of a
psychology of restoration.
It comes out of saying,
let's reach out,
let's restore, let's bring back.
And so some of my work
is to say it's possible.
And I hope that a
movement of restoration
can start to take root all
over the world, where we start
to say, no, let's go actively
and reconnect with nature
and reclaim it.
And there's sort of
two parts to that.
And the one is active
restoration of wild places.
But the other is to
restore ourselves,
to reconnect with a
deeper part of our self.
Because what I see happening
is any type of healing that you
do from trauma, any type of
reconnecting with your being
that you do, if you
can get under all
of the patterns of
compensation and neuroses
that modern life gives us and
touch your own wild being,
what happens is this
overwhelming feeling of enough,
you know?
There's this feeling
that I am enough.
This is enough.
There is enough for all of us.
And so some of the
work that I see
has to happen out in the
active physical space
of reclaiming wilderness.
And other parts of it has
to happen inside of us.
And we have to
discover what needs
to be restored in us as a part
of the restoration movement.
Because if you can touch
that feeling of enough,
your whole what drives
you in life changes.
And the desire to consume and
have more and try and attain
more gives way to a
whole different way
of wanting to be
in life, a way that
is much more about sharing your
essence, feeling fulfilled,
being involved in things
that are meaningful to you,
that you care about.
The whole value directive
changes when you
start to live from that place.
So I think that's going to
be part of the restoration
movement.
JORDAN THIBODEAU:
Excellent, now for us
people who don't spend a
lot of time in the bush,
and for you, you're able to do
boarding school in Johannesburg
sometimes.
Were there practices
that you use
when you're living in
Johannesburg to get yourself
back in touch with yourself?
BOYD VARTY: Yeah, I mean, I
think all of the modalities
that we're seeing taking root
in the Western world, yoga,
meditation, breath
work, that sort of stuff
is certainly doorways to it.
But I think another dimension
is to live on the feeling.
So it's kind of like your
body is a wild animal,
your body knows it
has a different way
of being in the world.
And it's, Mary Oliver says,
you don't have to be good.
You don't have to walk on
your knees for 1,000 miles
through the desert.
You just have to let the
soft animal of your body
want what it wants.
So what I see, what wildness
is is getting in touch
with living on the
feeling, getting
in touch with your
inner guidance system,
you're inner tracker,
you're inner compass
and living on that instead of
all the shoulds and have tos.
And I think we talked about
a little bit over lunch,
so much of the work
that I do with people
to help them get in
touch with wildness
is, I'm doing this thing.
How does it make you feel?
It makes me feel terrible.
OK, then if it makes
you feel terrible,
not up here, in your
body, you might want
to think about not doing that.
And the other side of that
is, what makes you feel good?
And I mean the physical
sensation of expansion,
of energy moving, of the feeling
that makes you go like this.
If you can identify the
things that bring that
into your body, that feeling
of aliveness and awakeness,
that is a wild guide.
That'll help you go wild.
And it'll help you live
from a different place.
So most of us are so stuck in
the mental constructions that
were presented to
us by modern life,
all the things we should
do and have to do,
that we shut off
those instinctual,
that part of ourselves
that just knows,
the part of ourselves that
when a golden retriever runs up
to you, just loves it,
the part that just can
recognize these innate places.
We shut all of that down so that
we can live up to some ideal,
so that we can get through it.
But to get back in touch
with the feeling, that
is your internal
guidance system, that
is your instincts that will lead
you to a different way of being
in the world.
So that's become
the core for me,
to check in with
my body compass.
And if my body compass is
giving me a strong no, you know,
we are the only
creatures in the world
who would walk up
to an elevator,
see the door open, and a creepy
person is standing inside,
and get in out of politeness.
Animals don't do that.
If they get a feeling that
there's something wrong,
they trust that feeling.
And so work out
what you're feeling,
the sensation in your body
that says yes, work out
what that feeling is.
Get in touch with
the feeling that
says no, not as a mental
construction, but as a body
sensation.
And then just keep turning
towards the thing that says
yes that brings you to life.
And that's going to give you
a look at what your life would
be if you were willing
to really live wildly.
And that's quite an
adventure to go on.
Yeah, so that's one
of my practices,
to live in the feeling.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: Fantastic,
that's very applicable,
so thank you.
Now in the '40s when apartheid
started to become formalized,
there were rules
that whites couldn't
employ blacks or whatnot.
And I believe it was
your grandfather who took
a stance on that in the bush.
Can you talk about that?
BOYD VARTY: Yeah,
I mean we grew up
in a country that
was severely divided.
The apartheid regime
tore people apart.
And it assigned
values to people based
on their race,
which is something
that the country continues
to try and heal from.
But we were lucky.
Because there was
something about being
out in the wilderness
that allowed us,
as a village of all
races, to be free of that.
Because when you go out
into nature, when you go out
and track a lion together, which
is a difficult and dangerous
endeavor in an environment
that is hostile to you,
if you're not aware
and if you're not
willing to really be
there for each other
and connect with each other.
The preposterousness of creating
divides via race is just,
it's impossible to be with
someone in real life situations
and maintain some kind of mad
structure that segregates.
And so at Londolozi
we were always
lucky to be involved
in a shared endeavor,
to be in situations that cut
us away from those regimes.
And so we were a very
united village, always.
And that's why when
Mandela came out of prison,
my family worked with a
guy called Enos Mabuza.
And Enos was an interesting guy.
He worked for the
apartheid government.
But he was actually
working for the ANC.
So he was placed in a position
to work out what the apartheid
government was trying to do.
And at Londolozi,
he saw a village
that was united by this shared
endeavor of restoration,
of being in nature together.
And he had always
said to us that this
is a place where we're
pouring the cultures together.
And it's an example of what
South Africa should be.
And so when Nelson Mandela was
released from prison, he came.
Enos organized for him to come
and live with us at Londolozi.
And to have his presence
there and to have
him advocate and
say, he actually
wrote that this was
a model, that he
hoped to see all
people living together
in harmony with each other
and the natural world.
And he hoped that it would be
a model that South Africa could
build on.
So I feel like some
of the work that I
do is in this idea of
the village building.
And village building, one
of the core pieces of it
is what happens when we're
involved in a shared endeavor
together.
And being out there
in the natural world,
everywhere you looked,
there was shared endeavor.
And that shared
endeavor cuts away
all of these
man-made constructs.
And again, I see that part
of the expansion of that idea
is to start to think of
ourselves as humanity together
involved in this endeavor on our
planet and to put our energy,
as humanity, into
developing systems that
allow us to live well all
together on our planet
and belong to it in a
much more profound way.
So again, I've
seen the microcosm.
And I feel like to
think of ourselves
as a grand global collective
working together in that way,
in harmony with
nature and each other.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: So you had
mentors from the Shangaan tribe
who taught you a
lot about the bush.
And you also mentioned
there was a gentleman who
was kind of like a rebel.
And he taught you how to track.
Can you talk about your
relationships with him
and how you learned
to track from him?
BOYD VARTY: I was
extremely lucky to be
exposed to some of the
best trackers in the world
from a young age.
And one of the amazing
things about the Shangaan men
who I grew up with is that
they had grown up hunting
and gathering on the land.
And so their entire
psychology was so
connected with that wilderness.
And to be out
there with them was
to see a place, to see how
a wild place talks to you.
There's all these signs.
The great trackers, they
know where the animals move.
They know the speed at
which they're moving.
They know where they drink.
They know the bird calls.
They can tell when a bird
is alarming at something.
It's like being in--
it's like a language.
The wilderness has a language.
And the great trackers speak
that language so beautifully.
And so I spent as much
time as I could with them.
And they slowly started
to teach me that language.
And as you learn
that language, it's
like when you're in
a foreign country
and you start to
pick up the odd word.
And then those odd
words become sentences.
And then as you
learn the language,
you start to really
feel like you're
becoming a part of the place.
So I was given that
opportunity to be with them.
And the great
trackers are, they are
examples of living in
constant creative response.
They never have a plan.
And yet, they always
get onto a track
that starts to inform the
way they're going to live.
They're all rogues and poets.
And you can never tell them what
to do because they're always
very present in the moment.
It's like, I will do what
this moment is asking of me,
where this track
is directing me.
What the land is saying at
this moment is what I'll do.
And so I was given
a different way
of thinking about living
by being with them.
Instead of having all
of these goals and plans
that if you hit them,
you might be valuable,
you might have done
something worthwhile.
And rather to find--
this value is
defined by external.
They are much more still.
And then they feel
their curiosity
attached to something.
They feel an interest.
They feel the moment
speaking to them.
And then that drives
their actions, not out
of trying to hit
markers, but out
of this profound
connection with the way
the moment is unfolding.
And so what I got from
them was a different way
of thinking about living
your life, one that
is guided from the inside as
opposed to from the outside,
one that comes out of
presence, curiosity,
interest in the moment, rather
than trying to derive value
based on a set of externals.
And so I would say that
was the core of what
being with them was about.
It's also like, it's
an amazing thing
to be with people who just
feel so cared for by the land.
They feel like so
in touch with it.
And they know that everything
they need is there.
So there's not the
scarcity that we
live with of like I got
to get enough, I got to--
They live in this
very abundant place
where it's like
they will always get
what they need from the land.
It will be there.
In the moment, something
will happen and we'll get it.
So it's like the whole
psychology is abundant rather
than accumulative.
It's like trusting all the time.
When you hunt and
gather, you always
trust that you'll
get what you need.
There may be a few days
where you're hungry,
but you'll keep living.
You'll keep surviving.
If you know where to look,
if you know how to listen,
it's there for you.
So I think that's a really
interesting mindset, too,
that idea that, I can't remember
what movie it was in, there's
an idea that a truth and
a lie in our culture.
The truth is that if you're out
in the cold in the wilderness,
a bowl of soup and a blanket
will make you more comfortable.
The lie is that 1,000 bowls of
soup and 1,000 more blankets
will make you a thousand
times more comfortable.
And that's kind of
the core of what
I see, this sense of
always having enough.
And actually we touched
on it earlier, too,
the idea that we're obsessed
with security in this culture.
We are obsessed
with being secure.
And in a very strange way,
that security robs us,
the very thing that
we're obsessed with,
robs us of the feeling
of being alive,
the feeling of being engaged.
And it's this weird paradox
we're living in at the moment.
I mean, I work a
lot with men who
are looking to create the
next chapter for themselves.
And one of the
things that I see is
they're incredibly driven
to establish security.
And then at a certain
point, that security
starts to become depressing
in a very strange way.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: Why?
BOYD VARTY: Because I think
that deep inside of us,
we're programmed towards
certain curiosities.
We're programmed
to solve problems.
to be on the track.
We're not programmed
to find the animal.
We're programmed to be on the
trail, to be working it out,
to be trying to find it.
And that curiosity
nourishes us in a lot
of ways in the core of
our nomadic wild being.
And if you take that away
from us and just say, here,
here's 1,000 bowls of soup,
it starts to shut one down
in a very strange way.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: It's like
when you cage a lion, right?
BOYD VARTY: Yeah, It's
like when you cage a lion.
And too much uncertainty
is radically destabilizing.
But no uncertainty
is depressing.
So it's a weird paradox
that I think we're
trying to find our way in.
As I was saying,
neuroses is a substitute
for genuine suffering.
And sometimes like
in nature when
you are on the
track of an animal
or you've been out
there for a few days
and you're having to
work it out all the time,
it's incredibly engaging.
And your life feels very
full with this thing
you're trying to work out.
So definitely there's a point
of exploration in modern life
there for sure.
I think the very
things that we are
all desperately after are
also the things that we're
losing ourselves into.
And I feel like the things
we've been told to want
are not necessarily turning
out to be that fulfilling.
And then that becomes a
very interesting journey.
And it goes back to what
I was saying earlier.
It's like, if you could get
out of all the things you
should want to be successful,
well, what really calls to you?
What really fulfills you?
What really is meaningful?
And how do you start a journey
where you begin to track that
down, where you could begin to
find that wild thing out there
that would actually allow you
to rest into your own value
and to your own presence
So it's a very interesting thing
to go out and try and find.
And it begins with
actually asking yourself
about how you feel.
And I mean in a
very physical way.
Getting back to that
wild sense rather than
trying to live into
the cultural model.
Yeah, and just to watch
someone who is truly wild
and the freedom of it
and the peace of it
and the uncertainty of it.
And they just rest into it.
JORDAN THIBODEAU:
Excellent, your family
had the ability to
adopt a lot of animals.
And I believe your Uncle
John adopted a lion?
BOYD VARTY: Yes.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: Can you
talk about experience?
BOYD VARTY: Yeah, I
mean one of the things,
my uncle was a
documentary filmmaker.
And we were raised
on the idea that
as a documentary filmmaker,
you're an observer.
But the more time
he spent out there,
he started to have
relationships with wild animals.
He started to feel himself
much more connected to them.
And so in some ways, that
very scientific view of they
are the animals and here are
the people, at some point,
it has become part
of the problem.
Because we think of
ourselves as separate,
where really we're a part of.
And so when he started to
feel himself much more deeply
connected and he started
to break out of this idea
that we're observers of nature
and conquerors of nature
and start to explore we
are a part of nature,
he got closer to the animals.
And he interfered,
not interfered,
supposedly, but he found
an abandoned lion cub
and he decided
that he would raise
it to learn about
what it would be
like to be in very close contact
with a wild animal like that.
And lions are pride animals.
And so they bond with,
if you raise a lion,
you become part of its pride.
And so that was a
fascinating thing
to see that this
lioness, as she grew,
she considered the
people who were
around her, her pride, which
was fine when she was this big.
But when she got
up to 250 pounds
and she wanted to come and
cuddle with you on the bed,
it started to become a
little bit more challenging.
But like when you get a new
kitten and it eats your couch.
When you get a lion, like it
ingests your entire furniture.
Everything you've got.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: Wouldn't it
bring fresh kills to the house?
BOYD VARTY: Oh yeah,
bring fresh kills
and drag them into the tent.
He was living out
in a tented camp.
Drag them into the tent,
feed on them on the bed.
It was a wild experiment.
And there was one instance
where he had gotten malaria.
And so he was living in Zambia
in a very wild part of Zambia.
They took him and they
put him in a boat.
And they were taking
him to the hospital.
And this lioness ran next to him
while he got put in the boat.
And then as he
crossed the river,
she swam next to the boat.
And then she wouldn't
leave the other side
of the bank of the river.
She just sat there
waiting for him to return.
So it was a very deep
and beautiful bond.
And I think it again I
mean, I don't necessarily
think that everyone should
be raising wild lions.
But as an experiment, it was a
mark of how closely connected
we can become.
And yeah, it was an amazing
experiment and experience.
And he also raised
two leopard cubs
and released them
back into the wild.
Their mother had been
killed in a snare.
And then he raised them
and he released them back
into the wild.
So that was a success story.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: Fascinating.
Now your family decided to
take the model of conservation
in Londolozi and expand it
into another organization.
Can you talk about that?
BOYD VARTY: Yeah, so what
was established at Londolozi
was built on three pillars,
care of land, care of wildlife,
care of people.
And the idea being that
if you protected and built
a connection with the landscape,
thought of the animals
as your kin, that that place
would start to respond.
People would be able to
be with wild animals.
And people would come.
And in doing that,
you would generate
this economy of wildlife.
So that was the
model that was really
established at Londolozi.
And then in the early
'90s, we took that model
and we exported it all
over Southern Africa.
And so we went from
being this one operation
to being 33 operations around
the Southern African continent.
And it was taking that idea of
restoration and spreading it.
And it continues
to do that work.
A few days ago, we had a
guy come from the Pantanal
in South America who had a huge
cattle farm in the Pantanal.
And for years there, they have
been at war with the jaguar.
Because the jaguar
eat the cattle.
And he came and he drove around.
And he saw pride of lions.
He saw a leopard.
And I could see the
sort of cogs turning.
And on about the third day,
he looked at me and he said,
this used to be a cattle ranch.
I said, yeah, this used
to be a cattle ranch.
And he went back to
the Pantanal and he
put about 50,000 hectares
aside as a jaguar sanctuary.
And so this is the
idea of the way
that this idea of restoration
can start to travel.
Once people see it, it
starts to live inside people
as a sort of idea.
And then that idea can
start to spread itself.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: Fascinating.
Can you talk about
your experiences
when you were
learning how to drive,
at what like, seven
or eight years old,
when you were chasing
wild game with your uncle?
BOYD VARTY: Oh, yes, I mean,
if you grow up in the bush,
it's like growing up on a farm.
You get to drive from the
time you're really young.
People keep putting you
into the driver's seat
and you keep crashing Land
Rovers until eventually you
know how to drive them.
You peer over the sort of top.
But I had one encounter
where my uncle, who
was this documentary
filmmaker, he
would make me his
driver from the time I
was about seven or eight.
So we were filming
a pack of hyenas
that were feeding on a giraffe.
And the one hyena pulled
off the giraffe's leg
and it started running
across the savanna.
And so I started
driving the vehicle,
because he was on
the back filming.
And we were driving across all
of this really rough terrain.
And he screamed, left.
And I turned right by mistake.
Because I was seven years old.
And you can get your
left and rights wrong.
And he was he was bracing
for the other direction.
So he fell off the back.
The camera landed on his head.
The hyena ran off
around the corner.
He was in a complete rage,
chased me around the vehicle
for awhile, while he cooled off.
But that was kind of
standard procedure.
I mean, we were always stuck in
a furrow, stuck in a rainstorm,
lost in the middle of the night.
We were always, I mean it
was, trying to film leopards
is a difficult undertaking.
And they move off road.
And mostly what happens is
you break your Land Rover,
you break your camera, and
you don't see a leopard.
That seems to be the standard.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: Can you
talk a little bit more
about your experience
with Nelson Mandela?
BOYD VARTY: Yeah, sure.
So Mandela came on a few, he
came on a few separate trips
to Londolozi.
The first one being straight
after he came out of prison.
And he was in a period of rest.
It was kind of a
rest and readjustment
to his sudden
global icon status.
If you think, he
had gone into prison
as an unknown freedom fighter.
And he came out of prison
as this global icon.
And so he was in a state of
sort of adjusting to that.
And he needed time
to recover and get
used to being out of prison.
And so members of the
African National Congress
thought that at
Londolozi he would
have the space away
from international press
and everyone who wanted
to take his picture
to sort of have the room
to catch his breath again.
And it's true that lions
are quite a good deterrent
from people who want to come
and take pictures of you.
So it was good that
he was out there.
And it was an amazing time.
Because I was very
young at that time.
And my mother used to send me
to take him breakfast in bed.
And I would take his breakfast
and put it on a tray.
And we would have a
little discussion.
And I didn't, at the time,
really grasp the gravity of it.
And then sort of late
morning, he would go in
just in like a sort
of a sweat suit,
he would just go and
walk around the garden,
very quiet, very present.
And then I would
watch TV at night.
And we had this kind
of bunny, snowy TV,
you know, always adjusting the
bunny ears on it at that time.
And I would see images on
TV of the same quiet man
from the garden surrounded
by hundreds and thousands
of people as the scenes
of his release from prison
were broadcast all
over the world.
And it was my first encounter
with power through presence.
He had a way of bringing
himself to every encounter where
you could feel that he was not
trying to establish himself
in some hierarchy.
He had established
something in himself.
And that presence would
always work for him.
So I think the model
that we we're given
is power through dominance.
And he was really the model
of power through presence,
power through connection.
And he was amazing.
He had a manner about him where
he would humanize everyone
around him.
And so even when he met people
who had been the oppressors,
and he was renowned for
this, he would greet them
in their language.
He would ask them about specific
members of their family.
He would reach out to
anyone, in the moment,
he would connect first
and then sometimes be
very hard in establishing
the ground rules.
But first came this really
beautiful connection.
So that was amazing.
I saw, there was one incident
while he was staying with us.
My uncle and him used to
have breakfast every morning.
And my uncle would sit
at the head of this table
after being out making films.
And the future president
would sit on the left.
And they would sort of,
it was very relaxed.
They would chat.
And then there was a
much more official sort
of gathering, which was
happening at the camp.
And a whole lot of
people from the ANC
had come in, members
of the party.
And they were going to have
a very serious discussion.
And my uncle was going
to the discussion.
And as he walked
up to the table,
in an extremely rare moment
of tact for him, he realized,
I had better put
the future president
at the head of the table.
So he said, please,
Mr. Mandela, you must
sit at the head of the table.
And Mandela just
grabbed him by the hand.
He was very tactile.
He grabbed him by the
hand and said, oh, no, I
would never take your place
at the head of the table.
And he just would
downgrade the moment
and always lead, but in
this very relaxed way.
And between them,
he was maintaining
part of their ritual.
And he was not going to throw
the way they had been doing it
out of the window to make an
appearance for everyone else
at the table.
He goes, no, you sit
there, I'll sit here.
I'm still in charge, you
know, but in a really
humanizing and wonderful way.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: It's amazing
to see such a great person
like that, but then see
he's even better behind--
BOYD VARTY: Yeah, I
mean, just astounding.
I mean, everyone
in South Africa,
we called it Mandela magic.
Everyone in South Africa had a
story of a personal encounter
with him.
Everywhere you went,
people would say,
you know, it was like
he was everywhere.
He went to sports events we won.
And there was this
very strong feeling
that he raised
the entire outlook
and narrative of the country.
If you think of that
idea of entrainment,
you've heard this idea
that if you're around,
everyone's brains
has mirror neurons.
And as we interact with
people, our mirror neurons
start tapping into
their mirror neurons.
We start becoming like them
in a very specific way.
And the more present
you are, the more
you can shape other people's
mirror neurons around you.
And it's a kind of
like entrainment.
People sort of talk about it.
I don't know whether
it's true or not.
But I was very interested
when I heard it.
Because there was this
overwhelming feeling
that Mandela sort of
entrained the entire country
to a better version of itself,
to a higher consciousness,
to a stronger outlook.
And I feel like we're in
desperate need of more leaders
like that, who can model that
kind of heart and presence
and show us a
different way of being.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: Right
and that ties into ubuntu.
Can you talk about
what that word means?
BOYD VARTY: Yeah, I mean, ubuntu
is, he was the model of ubuntu.
He was the embodiment of ubuntu.
And ubuntu is an African value
that says, I am because of you.
And we experience the
deepest parts of ourselves
through our interactions
with other people.
And so one of the ways they say
it is, people are not people
without other people.
And in a more
collective society,
and if you grow up in
the villages in Africa,
it is more collective.
There is no--
I think of it as a we
consciousness, rather than
an I consciousness.
Everything is about the
well-being of the we,
rather than this
hyper-individuality that we see
in other parts of the world.
And so ubuntu is that.
It is I can't be
a person, sorry,
I'm smacking the microphone.
I can't be a person
without you being a person.
And we make each other human.
We make each other, we can
only bring our humanity out
in relation.
And it's an idea that
just becomes more and more
important in these times.
As we see more and more of
this kind of egoic obsession
with self, with self
and group, you know?
And it seems like we just are
forgetting how to humanize
each other in every moment.
And so to find
your own humanity,
to be kind to yourself, to
find that part of yourself that
discovers itself
in something else.
JORDAN THIBODEAU:
The last question
I have, going back to
Mandela and ubuntu.
There was a riot going on
that Mandela was seeing on TV.
And your dad had this quote
that encapsulated that.
Can you talk a
little about that?
BOYD VARTY: Yeah, just
after independence,
there was a thing
called the CODESA talks.
And the CODESA talks
were talks about how
they would have talks.
So talks about how the
nationalist apartheid
government and the
ANC would set up
a framework by which they could
create the handover of power
in the country.
And Mandela was staying with us.
And in the midst of these talks,
the right wing of South Africa
drove an armored car
into the conference room
where the talks were going on.
There was a huge uproar.
It was like the country
was on the brink of war.
And Mandela came out and he
said, he was very agitated,
and he said to my
father and uncle,
you will get me a
helicopter right now.
I need to fly to
be with my people.
And my father said to him, no.
And he said, you will
get me a helicopter.
I need to be with my people.
And my father said,
I am your people.
And if you go there, some
fool might take a shot at you.
And I won't do that.
I won't allow that.
So we'll get you an airplane.
And we'll fly you nearby.
And then your
security can assess
whether you can go there.
And he just stopped for
a moment and he went,
that's a better idea.
Let's do that.
It was just one of those
historical moments.
And really, like
the force of the man
and the ability to quickly
change course, you know?
That's a better idea.
Let's do that No need
to assert anything
beyond that, what's best.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: Excellent.
BOYD VARTY: Is that the story
you were thinking about?
JORDAN THIBODEAU: Yes,
that's exactly what it was.
Your dad can put another
notch in his belt,
argued with Nelson Mandela.
BOYD VARTY: Yeah, screamed--
told Nelson Mandela no.
Probably one of the few people.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: Do we
have any audience questions?
If not, I'm going to go
for online questions.
Can you talk about your
writing process for the book?
Did you outline,
plan extensively?
How long did it take
you to write the book?
What was your regular
practice [INAUDIBLE]??
BOYD VARTY: The
book started just
out of telling campfire stories.
And then I met some people
who said, well, you know,
you should write those
campfire stories down.
Because I wrote a
memoir in my 20s,
which is kind of funny
in its own right.
But there were a lot of amazing
encounters along the way.
And so first, I just
started capturing stories
and then started to sort of work
out how they fitted together.
And it was very organic.
I just, when something
happened out there,
I had a memory of
something happened,
I just started to
put it together.
And I just wrote.
One of the great things about
how that was at that time,
I just wrote out of the sheer
joy of capturing the stories,
you know?
It was like right at the time
when publishing was dying.
And everyone was like, no
one's publishing anything.
And I was just like, well,
these are my stories.
So I wrote them all down.
And what I discovered in
that is like stories are
a kind of medicine, you know?
And as humans, we're
narrative creatures.
We belong to certain stories.
And so part of learning
to tell your own story
is like learning to belong
to your own life in a really
unusual way.
And I think it's
another reason why
we need to tell the
story of restoration.
So that as a society,
it can become something
we start to belong to.
So I just wrote for the
joy of it and compiled it.
And out of writing
to that joy, I
was lucky enough to meet
an editor and someone who
actually knew how to
take all those stories
and put it together.
But the book, for me,
was one of those moments.
I didn't consider
myself a writer.
I just, I felt compelled
toward something.
And I just followed
it into a time
when there would be no
financial reward for it.
No one was publishing books.
It would probably
never go anywhere.
And I didn't care, because I
was enjoying doing it so much.
And that, I think, is
an interesting track
sometimes in life.
And then, of course, I had
this really crazy experience
where it did get published.
Someone did pay for it.
All these things that everyone
told me were impossible came.
But they were not my focus.
And so the learning
of that book for me
was just to live on the
feeling with no idea of what
the outcome can be.
Because you can't know.
And so many of the
people I work with now
will say to me, when I know
what the next thing is, then
I'll make some changes.
And I'm like, it doesn't
always work like that.
Sometimes you've got to be
willing to not know and just
step out into the
unknown on little clues,
on little feelings.
And sometimes an unexpected
outcome, like a book,
can come out of just enjoying
writing your campfire stories.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: Can you
talk about the challenges
and triumphs you
face when trying
to protect the animals within
and beyond the wildlife
preserves?
BOYD VARTY: Yeah, it's ongoing.
The challenges are
that we're losing,
we're losing more and more.
I feel like as we're losing
more and more our own ability
to be natural as people,
the natural world
is receding away from us.
And there's this weird thing
where, even the other day,
I drove down the west coast.
And I drove through all
the fires from Oregon
into California.
And that was right
at the same time
that the storm was
hitting Florida.
And I kept finding
myself saying like,
man, this is what the future is
going to be like all the time,
you know, heatwaves,
fires, hurricanes.
This is what the future
is going to be like.
And it's this weird, collective
denial, even in the language.
Because I was like,
this is not what
the future is going to be like.
This is what now is like.
And one of the
biggest challenges
is how do we get out of
this collective denial
that it is upon us.
We are in a great
ecological collapse.
And so how do we find our way to
something positive within that?
How do we start to gather up in
community as this change starts
to happen and find our way into
something more connected, more
loving, more compassionate
to ourselves, to the earth,
to community?
And I think I'm getting a little
bit away from the question,
but that is the big challenge.
How do we love what's
dying right now?
And some of that goes all
the way back to ourselves
and realizing that life is--
I used to be a radical
conservationist.
And I still believe in that.
But I really feel now
like the shift has
to come in human consciousness.
And one of the things that
we refuse in our society
is we refuse to believe
that we are going to die.
We hide our old people away.
We just, we refuse to accept
that that is coming for us.
And a society that is afraid
of dying is afraid of living
and afraid of exploring what
it would actually mean to live
in a really connected way.
And so some of the
ecological issues we face
are born out of
something inside of us.
And I feel like we have to build
a relationship with that place,
all of us, collectively,
and find our way into living
a life that reflects abundance
and enough within ourselves.
And that is going to create
the change in the environment.
That is going to
change our relationship
with the natural world.
And until then, we've just
got to love every moment
that we can, that we get
to have with a wild place.
So I don't know what
it's going to look
like in 20 years from
now, and to not be
crushed by that, to not be
overwhelmed by that feeling.
I don't think I got
anywhere near that question,
but that's what came out.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: Got it.
Well, thank you so much for,
first of all, writing this book
and sharing with
us your experience
and coming down here
to Google to answer
our questions here and join us.
So we're going to give
you a round of applause.
BOYD VARTY: Oh,
thank you, so much.
Great to be with you.